dos civiles se suman a los muertos
causados por la seguidilla de
lanzamientos de misiles de Israel en
Siria de hecho el de Esta media noche es
el cuarto ataque israelí en seis días y
el décimo en lo que va de 2023 según la
ong observatorio sirio de derechos
humanos de nuevo como el jueves y el
viernes Israel centro su bombardeo en
los suburbios de Damasco y el sur del
país con el objetivo de atacar no solo
el área del aeropuerto donde hay un
complejo iraní sino también posiciones
tanto de tropas sirias como de las
milicias pro iraníes que las apoyan en
palabras de la agencia Siria sana la
mayoría de los misiles que partieron
desde el golán sirio ocupado por Israel
fueron derribados por defensas
antiaéreas aunque la ong detalló que al
menos dos misiles fueron interceptados y
que además de los dos civiles murieron
también un número indeterminado de
combatientes prohirán Cómo es común
Israel no ha hecho comentarios sobre
este último golpe sin embargo no hay
duda que esta recrudeciendo sus ataques
nocturnos contra lo que denomina
tiranías en Siria además de
contraposiciones de bashar a lassat y
del hesbolá libanés un eje Irán si
viajes bola que sin duda quiere combatir
a estos tres actores los culpa de la
entrada de un dron a priori iraní que
Israel destruyó al cruzar la frontera y
sobre todo de una explosión ocurrida en
el norte de Israel el 13 de marzo
causada por un hombre que se infiltró
desde el Líbano para evitar un nuevo
conflicto con Líbano Israel no ha
aclarado la identidad del autor y se
está cobrando cada represalia en suelo
sirio y en una de estas represalias el
viernes También mató a dos oficiales de
la guardia Revolucionaria iraní razón
por la cual desde Teherán han prometido